des photos de jonathan destin quand il
était enfant il y en a plein les albums
de son adolescence tout ou presque ont
disparu
elles sont sur la peau est décidée
touche t pourquoi as tu les années où
tout a commencé
forcément la raquette
plus dans le schéma en plus garder c'est
trop dur l'histoire de jonathan destin
c'est le calvaire d'un garçon un peu
rond que les autres élèves insultes tous
les jours depuis le cm2 et dans tous les
établissements qu'ils fréquentent des
brimades à répétition sur son physique
sur son nom de famille destin des coups
aussi quand le prof a le dos tourné le
gars ont subi pendant six ans
est ténue le thé chose comme ça en fait
mais après ça les îles matin qu'est ce
qu'on y peau en fait c'est ben t'es un
gros porc tu t'es juste comme ça et pas
après ça touche en fait c'est au fur et
à mesure dans l'entente de tout le temps
ça me touche et au fond
après les insultes le racket à
l'extérieur du collège chaque jour trois
grands lui soutire 5 euros l'argent que
sa mère lui donne pour déjeuner
l'adolescence s'enferment dans le
silence il ne dit pas un mot de son
d'enfer nous disait toute façon si tu as
quelque chose à tes parents ou à
quelqu'un eh ben on fera du mal à ta
famille on étire à moi dès que je
souffle en parle à une par an il y avait
toujours la phrase qui me revenaient de
la tête on va faire du mal à ta famille
un jour ses maîtres chanteurs lui
réclament 100 euros une somme que
jonathan n'a pas accablé par la peur et
par la douleur a cumulé toutes ces
années il décide de mettre fin à ses
jours il s'immole par le feu le long du
canal
ce que j'en tirais tous les jours
c'était c'était plus fort que la mort
c'est plus fort que le fait d'avoir mal
donc la solution pour arrêter tout ça
jonathan destin fini par se jeter dans
l'eau des voisins la perçoivent et
viennent à son secours
après deux mois et demi de coma jonathan
destin se réveille ses parents
découvrent alors l'enfer qu'il a vécu
les gens nous disent vous avez rien
jamais rien vu vais bien non on ne voit
rien les enfants qui sont harcelés et
qui cache cependant le voit rien on est
parent les mamans et papas et ben non on
s'en rend pas compte
si l'enfant ne dit rien s'en rend pas
compte
jonathan et ses parents ont porté
plainte et aujourd'hui il témoigne dans
un livre mettre au jour le passé pour
mieux affronter l'avenir un avenir où
jonathan destin devra encore subir de
nombreuses opérations chirurgicales
ses plaies intérieures il les soigne
avec un psychiatre puis dans un atelier
thérapeutique où il travaille le bois
échafaudé projet pas toucher
au revoir mon permis
[Musique]
à 18 ans jonathan destin espère être à
l'aube d'une nouvelle vie
[Musique]